news story this morning also out of
downtown las vegas one person is dead
another hurt after a shooting at fremont
and casino center that's inside the
fremont street experience this happened
at two o'clock in the morning metro
police tell us a group of people got
into an argument inside one of the
casinos the argument continued outside
where the shooting happened metro police
are still searching for the suspect
there we'll keep you updated on both of
these breaking news stories as they
continue to develop again this shooting
on fremont street experience i just
spoke to one person who was there at the
time and said there's a lot of commotion
and a lot of yelling and a lot of
gunfire there on the scene so it
happened right in the middle of
everybody out there on the fremont
street experience so as you can imagine
a lot of people pretty shaken up by that
of course we'll update you on both of
those stories good morning here on this
sunday morning thanks so much for
joining